[Music]
I'm excited to be back it's my second
year at CSS calm and welcome to my talk
why do we call HTML tags tags I'm Andres
Cuervo and before we get started I want
to tell you a little bit about a little
bit about myself I'm an XOR artist a
software engineer and an HCI researcher
so that means that I spend most of my
time building web-based VR and AR
experiences demos artworks stuff like
that but I also really like nerding out
about the history of HTML and CSS and so
that's what this talk is gonna be about
so before we answer the question that's
the name of this talk even though I'm
sure this audience being says CSS comp
is already familiar it's always good to
be really explicit so we'll talk about
talk a little bit about what tags with
the dad the tags that we're talking
about are so if we view the source of
any web page you'll see a giant HTML
document and it'll have two two types of
things the first will be the doctype and
that tells you what version of HTML
you're looking at and the rest of the
document will be composed of tags so if
we take for example the title the
content of the content of the tag is
example domain and that's what appears
in your browser tab in your browser tab
is the name but the tags themselves are
pieces of XML that are surrounded by by
greater than and less than symbols and
yeah so this is what I mean when I'm
referring to a tag and everyone who
works on the web has to know this and
works it works with this very intimately
and
a few months back I was thinking about
why we call these things tags though
only two sort of example or only two
like definitions for the word tag that I
can think of outside of this are the
tags like the things that come on your
clothing and tags are tagged like the
children's game where kids run around
and tap each other and neither of those
seem like obviously related to what
we're talking about here
and after some googling I couldn't
really find a simple answer and that's
what led to the development of this talk
so in order to answer where that word
where this word comes from we have to
take a short trip through the history of
HTML and the so the first document to
actually standardize HTML was published
by Tim berners-lee in November of 1995
and it was called hypertext markup
language 2.0 and that's because HTML
itself had already been around since
around 1990 and in it there's one
particular line that's pretty
interesting to us which is HTML
documents our sgml documents with
generic semantics that are appropriate
for representing information from a wide
range of domains and that's just a
long-winded way of saying that hTML is
good at representing a bunch of
different information types so at this
time there were only 18 HTML tags but
even with that limited set people were
able to express a bunch of different
document types and that would only grow
with the later introduction of more tags
and CSS but for our purposes this is
interesting because it mentions that
hTML started off as an sgml document and
so that needs to the limit that the next
natural question which is what is sgml
so it stands for standard generalized
markup language and it preceded HTML
being standardized in 1986 and it
contains it's it's actually not a markup
language itself but rather it's a meta
Markham it's it's it's meant to define
the medicine tax for markup languages
that hope to be general themselves and
so it contains to in in that mission to
stay really broad it only contains two
types of things the first are called
type valid in the document and these are
things that with that this is a tag at
the top of the document that tells you
what type of document you're looking at
and this sounds really familiar because
it's the doctype that we saw at the
beginning in our example HTML file and
then everything else in sgml is known as
tag valid where all of the content in
the document is surrounded by an XML tag
and those are the two sorts of things
and this sounds really familiar because
this is what the first version of HTML
was SPECT against but this doesn't
really answer our question because there
is something that even precedes sgml
which is GML and both of them were
created by this person Charles Goldfarb
at IBM and he talks as early he talks
about talking about tags as early as
1969 as in the this like sentence
fragment where he talks about quote
using an unfilled in outline of tags as
a prompter from which to create a new
document and so this is where we sort of
first see the word tag resemble resemble
a thing that we would look we would look
at in HTML and recognize which is as a
container for data and if we were to
stop here this is what the chain would
look like and that's pretty short but we
can we can go further down the rabbit
hole and ask where did the tag the rid
of the usage of tag in 1969 come from
and this was easy when we were asking it
about HTML because there's a document
that tells us it's it's an sgml thing
but so far as I could find there was no
there was really no reference to where
the word tag came from in
in the original versions of GML and XML
which were developed alongside each
other and so in order to get at this
question I took I borrowed a page from
the field called etymology so let's talk
about that for a second
etymology is defined as the study of the
origin of words and the way in which
their meanings have changed their
history and so typically etymology is
used to study words through hundreds of
years or thousands of years of change
and so if we take the word cascade as in
cascading stylesheets then we can see
that it comes to English from this long
series of French Italian and Latin for
to fall and that makes sense because the
definitions are pretty related and that
it's actually pretty old word in English
coming in sometime in the mid s'en in
mid 17th century and so while this is a
much more involved process we can take a
cue from what etymologists and linguists
do here by trying to find the earliest
instance of the word tag in computing
and so in in trying to research this
question the earliest instance that I
can find it was credited to this person
emile leon post and post was a computer
scientist a or he was a mathematician
but he made sort of fundamental inroads
in theoretical computer science he was a
contemporary of Alan Turing's and he was
a logician and a mathematician so he
introduced this idea of a tag system in
a paper in 1943 called formal reductions
of the general combinatorial decision
problem and while we won't go through
the whole paper it's useful to
understand what it's doing in order to
understand why why the why the word tag
is appropriate here so the paper itself
is describing a computational model for
producing words arbitrary words from
production rules and that sounds really
abstract and hand-wavy so here is a very
very minified example
if we have a if we have a very simple
alphabet that only has four letters in
it ABC and H and we we say that whenever
we see an A we add on this string si si
bah and whenever we see a B we add on
CCA and so on with Si and si si then we
can take any initial word and start
transforming it so if we start with baa
then we take a look at that first letter
and we see that B goes to C CA and so we
tack that on and then there is a formula
for every time we pick a production rule
we truncate the front of the string with
some amount of letters or by some amount
of letters and that changes throughout
the string but the one fundamental thing
is that you keep tacking on the end of
to the end of the string that preceded
it until you finally hit a letter that
you can no longer produce a production
rule for or you reach a chain that you
that is so small but you can't delete
anything from it and so yeah if we look
at this sequence not only does this look
like a little stack but it looks like
the ends of each each successive word
are sort of chasing each other and in
fact there is a footnote from that
original paper footnote 12 if you're
curious where post-credits this person
BP gill with with noting that the that
the axioms look like they're chasing
each other and so he gave he suggested
the name tag and so in fact in this
usage we post would have called this a
tag operation and while this usage is
slightly different it's it's probably
fair to say that one Emil posts work was
really well received during his time and
too it was it would go on to influence
language designers in the next in the
preceding decades and so yeah there's
there's sort of two possibilities one is
that the word tag comes from the common
the common word for like a tattoo tag a
piece of clothing but this introduced
find like finding this evidence seems to
point to the children's game of tag
influencing BP guilt and so this is the
final chain of etymology that I came up
with for where we get the word tag in
HTML and the word for the children's
game actually comes as far back as the
1700s and so that led BP Gill to suggest
to post to use the word tag for his
seminal paper and that I'm speculating
sort of made its way into the lexicon of
computer scientists where someone at IBM
would later create GML and sgml and that
would go on to influence the very first
specs of HTML and so yeah this is I I
hope that this talk sort of does two
things for you
one that interests you in item ology a
little bit because I think it's really
cool and that too I hope that it sort of
encourages you to take a look at the at
the history of things that you might
have overlooked or seen as mundane
because if you whether it's in your
worker in your personal life there are
probably a million things around you
that you don't realize have probably
surprising and pretty interesting
histories yeah and that's all I have
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
[Music]